hey crazies in a previous video I said
this it's physically impossible for
light not to go with the speed of light
in a bunch of you've got all defensive
about it so today we're finally going to
answer the question can light slow down
well that depends
saying you wanted to send a laser
through something like this it's just a
piece of glass nothing special but
something weird happens when this laser
passes through it if we measure the
distance the light has to travel and the
time it takes to travel ventas okay so
we're not measuring that time with a
soft watch but but we can measure it as
long as we have the proper tool just go
with me here dividing the distance by
the time gives us a speed less than the
speed of light and if you're quick to
judge you might be like see it does slow
down but we haven't necessarily shown
that there's a problem with the way we
calculated that number dividing distance
by time doesn't give you a speed it
gives you an average speed and you all
remember what I said about averages in
the last video sometimes they have
meetings and sometimes they go meaning
is what we're looking for in science we
need to figure out if that average speed
has meaning so let's take another look
at that light it almost looks like it
has drag on it kind of like a person
trying to run through mud except dragony
happens when a solid tries to pass
through a fluid light is not a solid and
this glass prism is not a fluid a common
explanation is that light ceases to
exist for a moment as it's absorbed by
the atoms in the glass it's a nice
simple explanation for beginners but
it's wrong we've already seen that
electrons and glass can't absorb any
wavelengths of visible light to jump to
higher energy level that's why it's
transparent another common explanation
is that light doesn't travel in a
straight line it keeps bouncing off
atoms along the way Oh
so wrong if that were the case different
parts of the beam would come out of
different parts of the glass randomly
but we know the beam is very controlled
and very predictable something else must
be going on here we need to stop
thinking of light as if it's a stream of
bullets even if you imagine the light is
made of photons those photons are not
bullet light is a wave which means we
need to worry about wave interference
when you have two or more waves in the
same spot they can
vine to form one way isn't the original
beam only one light wave though well
technically it's a bunch of waves moving
together plus the original beam isn't
the only light in that glass the moment
the beam comes into contact with the
glass its atoms start to vibrate in
response that vibration causes all those
atoms to emit their own light most of
the light cancels except for one
particular direction the forward
direction the point is when you combine
all those waves together they just look
like one beam traveling slower than the
speed of light but is the light actually
traveling slower that depends on what
you mean by light it's a language issue
I think everyone agrees that one single
photon is light but this beam has a
bunch of photons in it if you also refer
to that beam as light ensure light slows
down and material but when I said it's
physically impossible for light not to
go at the speed of light I was referring
to individual massless photons which
always go to same speed beams of light
don't always have the same properties as
their photon so when you refer to that
beam as light or a bunch of light let us
know down in common thanks for liking
and sharing this video and a special
thanks goes out to patreon patrons like
Andy Kirkham go above and beyond don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video I suggested that math
wasn't the language of the universe and
you had a lot to say serve 75 and a few
others took the extreme opposite
position and said math wasn't even a
language which is an interesting
perspective they agree to symbols we use
to represent math Arling but that math
itself is something more fundamental
than the universe whether you're writing
out math symbols or you're writing out
the translated English sentences you're
doing math you're just going through
logical steps and those steps are the
real math but I think two problems with
this argument one some logically severe
doctors in the real universe doesn't
have those two things like electrons and
photons don't calculate the path they
travel they just move were the ones that
do the calculating science maps 2012
asked what might actually be a more
testable question can the universe be
axial ties in math there's a bunch of
things you can prove and a short list of
things you can the things on that short
list are called axioms which are things
we must assume to be true for math to
even work in the first place like a time
zero equals zero regardless of whatever
a is if you can find and agree on a set
of axioms for our physical laws then you
couldn't say the universe is inherently
mathematical the problem is physics
can't even agree whether or not Newton's
laws or conservation of energy momentum
are more fundamental let alone whether
either of them are an axiom the dark
slide says the symbols I used in the
video were specifically for English is
it true I've always been under the
impression that the scientific community
agreed on the symbols that we use
including the parts of the community in
countries with languages that aren't
Latin they let me know in the government
Rick Clark pointed out that units of
measure are completely made up by you
that's true
they're completely arbitrary but a lot
of theoretical work is done without
regard for units at all the equations
can be written to show relationships
between measurements that are true for
any unit so I'm not sure this piece of
information works in my favor okay now
on to separating the comment response
after counting opinions and some ups on
those opinions the consensus is to leave
the common responses as
is for now hopefully in the future
YouTube will eventually extend the time
for mobile endcard I also tried it on
the most recent bloopers video and I'm
not sure I like how they look anyway
lastly thanks to several new patrons on
patreon we've reached another goal you
can see the payoff at some point in the
next month I'll see you then thanks for
watching
[Music]